let's go next to our caller from the 361
area code who's calling today from 361
blow this Dilek calling in from texas
isn't me yes it is bill from texas yep
all right so I just wanted to ask so
it's pretty clear bernie is not gonna be
winning this nomination but is it
overwhelmingly likely the joe biden
necessarily gets a majority not that I'm
advocating any contested convention but
I was just curious is he gonna get like
an outright majority I believe that he
was I believe he is remember Bernie said
whoever has a plurality should get the
nomination so I don't think it'll make a
difference Biden will certainly have a
plurality I think there's a good chance
he ends up with a majority as well by
the time it's all said and done yeah
yeah I know Bernie said that he wouldn't
contest it basically but I was just
thinking that if Biden somehow failed to
get a majority I didn't know so be a bad
sign for the general election if that
happened I don't believe so and again
burnt like I said Bernie said at that
debate whoever has a plurality should be
the nominee so I don't think it's gonna
be an issue all right other than that at
this point um with the coronavirus and I
guess stuff going on with oil prices do
you have any basic assessment of are we
at a great risk for another recession
you know I think the answer is probably
but I can't control it
and therefore I'm not going to try to
guess so so basically you know at at my
age my plan financially remains
unchanged which is if this is the great
destruction if this is the beginning of
the end of the United States it doesn't
really matter where I put my money I'm
gonna lose it all so under the
assumption that this is not the end and
that in the past every downturn has been
followed by a recovery my plan is to
continue just investing in index funds
mostly equities with some bonds as
appropriate for my age
- my allocation and just keep
accumulating shares with the idea that
over the long term I'm gonna do okay and
then that way I don't have to worry so
much about is it or isn't it a recession
I'm not trying to time anything or or
any of those things that's my approach
alright um other than that I guess my
last question is just about Michigan in
particular I noticed that if you compare
bonds lead at this point to Hillary's
lead at this equivalent point his is
actually lower and she didn't even end
up winning that so what do you think I
don't know if you have any salsa mich me
in particular and our Democratic odds
and taking it back for their column no I
mean we're gonna assess that all in a
lot of detail once we get closer to the
general but no particular thoughts on
that bill thank you for the call I
really do appreciate it